chief white house correspondent nancy
cordes joins us now she was
inside the capitol during the
insurrection nancy good morning
we just saw how close lawmakers came
to the mob in many cases just moments
from interacting with them
what are what are republicans saying now
after they've heard this case
well many of them came out of day one of
opening arguments
anthony and understandably said that
this was horrific
uh reliving what they went through that
day and what was really interesting was
to see
how many of them said that the case that
the impeachment managers laid out
that the president was in part
responsible
was compelling senator lisa murkowski
who you heard in nicole's piece
said that it's clear that he should
never be president
again john thune of south dakota a
member of leadership said that they made
a strong
showing now i talked to a top republican
aide
late in the evening and he said he still
thinks that
at most 10 republicans will vote to
convict he argued that
anything beyond that would require the
kind of political courage
that we haven't seen in some time in his
words but 10 is still a lot more than
republicans were predicting
just a few weeks ago so this is a really
fluid situation
anthony and one big wild card is
republican leader mitch mcconnell no one
seems to know exactly where he stands
if he comes down on the side of
conviction then all bets are off
former president trump starts laying out
the lawyers for former president trump
started laying out his case tomorrow
what do we expect well based on the
legal briefs that they have already
submitted they are going to argue that
president trump
did nothing wrong at all that there was
no way he could know that this
uh insurrection would take place that
when he said that his
supporters should fight that he didn't
mean it literally and they're probably
going to play clips of
of other lawmakers using similar
language
over the years but what they're going to
have to explain
anthony is why then he did so little
after
this insurrection began nancy cordes
thank you nancy